I think one of the interesting things
you guys are doing here is related to
fraud prevention how do you guys stop
online fraud right well it's a really
important issue for us because any time
you're giving out something for free
there's there's a possibility that fraud
is going to creep into the system and
just make your whole product kind of
worthless to a retailer so we looked at
some point into using IP addresses you
know knowing knowing bad IP addresses
from users looking at web browsers the
kind of traditional way to fight fraud
and then we realized we had such a rich
set of signals from the social data so
you know we have from at least from our
first campaign from skype that we know
so far we launched a campaign there
where you could if you like darbar and
you can get a free skype code we found
that our fraud rates were better than
the industry average basically because
we had the social data to tell us
whether user was was fraudulent or not
so if you think about it it's really
hard for someone to have sign up for
multiple it's so easy to sign up for
multiple email accounts I'm sure we all
have several don't wonder you don't give
real people do things with a facebook
one is it becomes really apparent which
which account is real or not real
because you know you have more friends
on your real account you update it to it
more often you get all that data to know
you know how often to someone update
their status what what is their profile
pic how many friends do they have such a
rich set of data that even though you
know I our algorithms we started I think
they're solid I don't think we by any
means expand it gone to the limits of
our social date for data frog filtering
capability but because if signals are so
strong we're actually able to get a
really good signal that's very
interesting are using aggregated social
data from different social nets or is
this mostly Facebook that is is the
biggest use it has the biggest use to
you right now Oh Facebook is the big
issues to us right now because facebook
credits is the most popular incentive
that we're offering I see we have a
Twitter product where you can
incentivize someone tweeting we haven't
actually used it for social data
from for fraud filtering huh okay so so
if I'm an engineer and I'm building an
application and I want to stop online
fraud um what's the first thing I should
do I really think other than just you
know I think engineers will tend to
design an algorithm for it instead think
of things that you can do and natural
signals out there because you know your
your AI algorithms is crazy and
complicated as they are they're only
going to be as good as your signals if
Facebook is actually Facebook Connect is
pretty decent you have to you can check
if an account is verified or not it
needs to be verified by a mobile phone
number rather than just an email account
or something that's easy you know
everyone has limited limited mobile
phones so um yeah I consider that and i
would actually really even consider
policy things so um brother that's my
tendency is to go with the practical one
of the interesting things that we talked
about before was when you mentioned that
the online fraud doesn't always come
it's not always a trickle it often comes
in sort of a blast or like one big storm
explain that phenomenon and in what that
means um I think what happens we
actually had so what happened for a
while was that there was a number of
people who figured out of credit card
number that worked on one of our
retailer sites that wasn't a real credit
card number or maybe it was a stolen
credit card number I I don't even know
and there were it just got out they must
have posted about it in a forum or
things like that so all of a sudden
overnight we had tons of fraud that came
in in one big burst because what happens
is one person figures out how to fraud
the system what's the first thing
they're gonna do they're going to spread
the word to all their friends oh
especially since what we do a lot is
facebook credits so you know these are
people who play play games are used to
gifting their their friends things every
day and they gift it with the ability to
fraud so will basically get a big burst
of a fraud in one night and have to
figure out that they're just
been times where I figured out a signal
that will get rid of this rod and the
pushed it within 10 minutes oh good i'm
going to change to shut this down so the
first thing you want to do is come up
with some kind of control or some kind
of velocity control so you can realize
when there's a potential go talk to a
lawyer so go for it that it could be
happening because you know you're not
realistically monitoring these things
every day the velocity of some
particular metric or set of metrics that
you're kind of watching across time
right look what your particular campaign
just seems to be picking up speed and
it's just a little bit officious yeah um
so that's the first piece to code up
which is difficult um you know it's not
straightforward how to calculate that
kind of thing and then when you go into
it you can look at the data and pretty
pretty quickly come up with some kind of
signal I think that's actually the easy
part is coming up with some kind of
signal when you look at eat as a person
when you look at just 5 or 10 of these
fraudulent users you can usually find
some characteristics pretty quickly that
they all have women